amelia empezó un rompecabezas a las 12
56 pm y lo terminó a la 1 33 pm
en cuánto tiempo armó el rompecabezas
amelia bien podemos ver que ella empezó
el rompecabezas a las 12 56 pm
y también podemos ver que ella terminó
el rompecabezas a la 1 33 pm
y si observas ambas obras son pm y
estamos suponiendo que seguimos en el
mismo día eso significa que no le llevo
todo el día desde la mañana hasta la
noche el armar el rompecabezas le llevo
sólo una parte de la tarde así que ella
empezó a las 12 56 pm lo puede escribir
aquí empezó a las 12 56
pm a las 12.56 minutos
y queremos saber cuánto tiempo
transcurrió hasta la 1 33 pm
los voy a escribir aquí la 133
m la una con 33 minutos
que es cuando ella terminó el
rompecabezas bueno de las 12 56 pm a la
1 pm a la una en punto podemos ver
cuánto tiempo hay de las 12 56 a la 1 pm
hay solamente 4 minutos 4 minutos
hay 4 minutos entre las 12 56 pm y la
una en punto y después de la una en
punto a la 133 hay otros 33 minutos así
que déjame escribirlo
aquí tenemos otros 33
min
así que amelia tardó cuatro minutos más
otros 33 minutos en armar el
rompecabezas cuatro minutos para llegar
a la una en punto y treinta y tres
minutos después de la una en punto
entonces ella terminó el rompecabezas en
37 minutos 37 minutos desde que inició y
ya acabamos